and those loosen restrictions may help a
small theater in town
bowab stage town square hosted its very
first production on friday since the
shutdown in march
8 news 9 reporter kristen drummond joins
us live in the newsroom with their
efforts
kristin well sasha the curtain is slowly
rising again for community entertainment
it remains a challenge with the coveted
restrictions but i'm told
the show must go on i'm very grateful to
be back on stage actually
the spotlight shines again on angelique
janowski the former cirque du soleil
zumanity dancer tells me
she's grateful to find work after nearly
a year
i know that for a lot of artists it's
difficult we don't know when other show
gonna reopen
she now performs in the apparo show a
small cabaret production
inside the baobab stage at town square
it's a group of us who have been in
entertainment in las vegas for a long
time
trying to put something together and
just bring a little bit of entertainment
back
the show opened on friday and is the
first performance back in this space
since march
nicole dunn is the production manager
and calls it an opportunity for the
artist to share their craft
while following state mandates that
includes social distancing and capacity
restrictions but
after sunday it may change a bit
probably i'll be running around with
measuring tapes
seeing where we can fit chairs and if we
can if we can't we'll stay at the
capacity we're at it's important
and crucial i think wasa kuala bali
tells me the production helps revive the
arts in town
the stage owner adds it gives the
community an option when seeking
entertainment
life to our venue and to this mall and
to
people's hearts while giving janowski
and others a place to share their talent
we just want to bring hope and joy
small theaters must consider social
distancing which is
why lifting capacity restrictions may
not help certain venues
reporting live in the newsroom kristin
drummond 8 news now